Many strains of corona virus have
come into our world like your delta
omak as well as the latest one if you talk about it then that is your J ave
strain but if
we talk about your corona virus
why does it only affect our lungs?  When it does this,
our corona virus and the
lungs have similar type of receptors present in both, due to which the
corona virus is absorbed by our lungs and then what it does after going
into our lungs, it creates its strains.
Increases it and starts its reproduction there. The
immune system of our body recognizes this thing and
forms antibodies for it, due to
which we also get fever at this time. As well as
this, it affects our macro phages.
Stimulating
Cytosis